maintenant devenir la biographie de
michelle obama s'écouler à plus de 10
millions d'exemplaires
l'ex première dame a décidé de porter
l'essentiel de ses mémoires à l'écran
talent est une femme beaucoup plus
indépendant que l'un des anciens de
première dame des etats-unis alors
carrière qui donnait le premier emploi
alors qu'il s'est fait présenter comme
travailleur social quand même un
événement important politique sociale
[Musique]
dans son film michelle obama revient sur
son enfance à chicago sur le racisme sur
les enjeux de classe sociale sur les
sacrifices consentis pour accompagner
son époux jusqu'à la maison blanche
toutes les expériences qu'ils ont forgés
a eu le courage de dire quels autres
retrouve richard fassis qui m'inspire
c'est pas juste le fait qu'elle ait pu
passer à travers ces moments là mais
c'est dans la façon que l'a toujours
fait elle reste toujours digne classe et
au delà mais ici pas de grandes
révélations mais on retrouve le ton et
l'attitude qui ont fait le succès de
l'ancienne première dame
moi ce que j'ai aimé dans le film par
rapport au livre ses devoirs de voir
tant de femmes ensemble
elle essaye de donner du pouvoir aux
femmes et que les femmes croient en elle
est aussi que toutes les personnes qui
veulent résister ou discours ambiant
peuvent prendre leur place
[Applaudissements]
devenir est la plus récente
collaboration entre netflix et la
compagnie de production fondée par l'ex
couple présidentiel
la plus grande force du film est
d'insuffler le dose d'espoir dans cet
ensemble le tour de dire les choses de
trouver de vulgariser les défilés en jeu
tout en restant positive et pas trop
jovialiste et bien que le documentaire
soit un portrait de l'ex première dame
ce n'est pas moins un objet politique
chez clair que les gens vont regarder
document peut-être le liban plus suivie
à 10 6 98 peut-être ici nabi alexandre
charti radio canada montréal
[Musique]